World of Warcraft Dragon flight is an
exciting new chapter in the wow Saga
that introduces massive and awesome
changes to the way the game plays and
feels it introduces a brand new highly
customizable winged race called The
dragther Who come with their own
dedicated class the evoker the new Zone
the dragon Isles is huge gorgeous and
teeming with life and it's been
specifically designed to be explored by
Dragon riding yep Dragon riding as in
flying around on a dragon and of course
dragonflight also brings with it a new
level cap dungeons a raid and a
compelling storyline that will have a
big impact for the dragon Isles and the
rest of Azeroth with its focus on
dragons and their story dragonflight is
a return to Wow's High fantasy roots and
it's also the game's best entry point in
years it's perfect for new and returning
players alike
[Music]
Dragon riding is a whole new flying
mechanic available in the new dragon
Isles region there are four types of
dragon riding mounts the Drake Grotto
Drake veloca Drake and wilda Drake these
are so much more than a new group of
flying mounts you'll need to use
momentum to keep you in the air and
you'll level up your dragon riding skill
in the game using an all-new skill tree
once you get the hang of it you'll be
soaring around the dragon Isles taking
in the scenery in no time and since
blizzard designed the dragon Isles with
dragon riding in mind that scenery is
absolutely gorgeous as you explore the
dragon Isles and complete challenges
you'll earn new ways to customize the
look of your dragon riding Mount so you
can really make it your own dragonflight
introduces the drakthia revoker a
dragon-themed range DPS and healer class
along with a new origin story that will
delve deeply into azeroth's history the
drag Veer can swap between their
dragon-like form and a more human-esque
Visage at will they will also come with
a pair of neat aerial abilities soar
which allows a drag theater to fly
without a mount and glide which allows
you to jump off any ledge from any
height and safely float down to the
ground drachthier evokers will also have
brand new empowered spells which you can
charge up for more power along with
unique abilities making use of the
dragon's wings and tail to interrupt and
knock back enemies both being very handy
in a pinch drakthia revokers have an
enthralling new starting experience An
Origin story that will fill you in on
some exciting lore and they also come
with all sorts of new customizations you
can customize things like your
draftier's horns scales snout eyes and
armor there are literally millions of
possible combinations here the huge new
Zone the dragon Isles features four
incredibly varied leveling zones the
vibrant waking Shores the Lush and
grassy anarin planes the glacial azer
span and the pristine which is the seat
of power for the dragonflights but the
appeal of the Dragon Isles isn't Skin
Deep the region has depth too because
it's a hugely important place in Azeroth
past and now it's present as well magic
has returned to the dragon Isles for the
first time in 10 000 years and an
ancient enemy has drawn the drakthia and
the dragonflights back home as you
explore and battle mysterious and
monstrous new threats you'll learn so
much more about the world of Azeroth and
you'll also gain a glimpse at what the
future holds for all drag theory on top
of all that the dragon Isles also have
plenty of Simple Pleasures to enjoy like
fishing and cooking quests with members
of The Fan Favorite tuscar race as well
as hanging out with adorable new Ducks
which players can get as a pet who
wouldn't want to have a duck pal wow
dragonflight makes some major changes
that fans have been clamoring for new
talent trees let you take more control
over your character's progression than
ever before and with the new ability to
save and load character builds you can
hot swap between your raid dungeon and
PVP Builds on demand dragonflight also
adds new opportunities to specialize in
your crafting skills and now crafting
gear equips automatically when you're
doing your job and doesn't take up space
in your bags which is awesome as if that
weren't enough dragonflight introduces a
new more modern looking HUD that can be
customized to your exact needs and you
can now save your customized uis as
presets and swap between them whenever
you want between the dragon riding the
new drakthia evoker race and class combo
the gorgeous new region to explore and
those marvelous new quality of life
editions World of Warcraft dragonflight
has everything you could want from a
major MMO expansion whether you're a
seasoned Adventurer of Azeroth or you're
just dipping your claw in for the first
time dragonflight will take you to new
heights